when the giemo lift I mean there was
there was Warner Brothers had been
funding all of the pre-production him
MGM were in such trouble at that time
that that they couldn't participate
particularly and so what I recall is
that there was a lot of money had been
spent and that and we still didn't have
a green light do we go and find an
another director but by the time that
had happened we had written a one draft
with Guillermo and had already we fallen
in love with the story it would have
been hard to to prize that away from us
at that stage and in terms of Peter
directing it I think that it possibly
wouldn't have been made if he hadn't
agreed to direct it because there were
so many fraught entanglements with the
rights and with you know various the
estate that just there were there were
many issues involved in it so they had
to have a great deal of confidence that
that you know whoever directed it was
going to deliver a movie that they were
happy with in terms of the script we
started again which was a very peculiar
and odd thing to have written the script
really for one director and then to
completely peel it back and say no we're
gonna start again and we'll well we
imagine this there was a two thing I
felt responsibility as a producer on the
film understanding that now with the
director having gone that the film was
in jeopardy to some degree and I wanted
to make sure that we could make it and
also as Fran says you know having worked
on it for that length of time we were
emotionally engaged with it there's a
lot of action in The Hobbit and at some
point you and we did this it's like do
do you do the Eagles do you cut the
Goblin so you cut the stone Giants we
what do you lose from that book and we
had been getting a lot of letters and
children who come only come to the Lord
of the Rings
you know they've never sometimes never
seen it on screen and the letters are
lovely most of them go thank you very
much for making the Lord of the Rings
when are you going to make the Hobbit
and so you get this this feeling from
kids that that you wanted to find the
right tone so that it could be a
rollicking adventure that you tunnel out
the door with those characters that it
has the humor that's in the book that
it's not the Lord of the Rings
you know Redux or you know done again
that it that it that it's its own story
as Peter sees that you're just going
back on location that the main thing we
were able to do which was fantastic for
Andy is that Martin and Andy were able
to shoot the scene at the same time and
it was literally being shot at the same
time so we were on the set of the cave
set Martin was performing there were
cameras filming him and there were 50
and 50 or 60 motion capture cameras that
we had built into the rock work of the
set kind of around the around the rock
walls of the set that we're recording
Andy so any anything and he did anywhere
he moved was being captured so he never
had to do any post-production work on
this film every his entire performance
that you see was being done with with
that mountain alive and also in the even
though Gollum we wanted gone to look the
same to have the continuity between the
film's we the last 10 years as there's
been incredible progress made with
performance capture so the muscles that
we were able to put into the CG golems
face very very subtle muscles around the
eyes around the mouth we were able to
build a much more physically capable
puppet which allowed a hundred percent
of Andy's performance to be translated
to the puppet very very accurately the
technology exists now today to do
interesting things with the experience
of coming to the cinema and and and
that's happening at exactly the same
time that that young people especially
don't seem to be as interested and going
to the movies as we did when we were
younger and so I just think there's a
responsibility that we have as an
industry as filmmakers to look at the
technology and say how can we make this
incredible its magical mysterious
experience of going into a cinema in the
dark with a bunch of strangers how can
we make that more spectacular and more
not just to be taken but just more
immersive we
grew up with these stories we love them
we are fans fans made these films
because we often ask you know what do
you think the fans are gonna think and I
my answer is I think it's good you know
I'm a fan and and and we we try to do
things respectfully one of the things
but you have to make a film you have to
make a movie and for example there's not
a lot of women in this and and you feel
that wait
and thank God for Cate Blanchett you
know you feel the weight of that there
so we made that choice as a filmmakers
we created a female character we tried
to do so which you will see in the next
film played by Evangeline Lilly court
Arielle and we tried to do that in the
spirit of what would he do you know what
if he created a character how would he
do it and I'm so glad because when we
were at comic-con this this girl who was
a Lord of the Rings fan she was
incredibly nervous and she stood up and
she said I just want to tell you thank
you for doing that because when I was a
little girl and I read the story I
didn't know Gandalf what I made female
characters and and I made Gandalf a
woman which was genius and you think of
course that's what that's what that's
what kids do you know they adapt and
that's what we tried to do